welcome back it is a pandemic pastime
for many turning to new hobbies for some
it is collecting many items
popular decades ago have now seen a
revival in this new era
madison kimbrough showing us some of the
hottest collectible items out there
and some of them may surprise you
i collected uh funko pops to begin with
and then
i slowly come in here i moved to action
figures
to cards to comics
i think a lot of people are
rediscovering their collections you know
they're trapped at home and
during the pandemic with most of the
world stuck at home during the pandemic
nostalgia has set in
i have 120 records at home a revival in
which things like dvds vinyl records and
even pokemon cards are now popular again
here at brad's toys and collectibles
there are three main items brad howard
says
are asked for on a daily basis pokemon
is one of the
biggest brands right now going on
pokemon was not
nearly as what it was now i mean uh
pokemon cards that you could walk in at
any point and buy them at any time
nowadays people are waiting in line
the day they come out one of the biggest
ones that right now that we could ask
for
constantly is star wars i mean i know
it's the mother of all pop culture
and the other item flying off shelves
funko pops
they have just taken the collectible
world by storm they've only been around
for a few short years but in that time
they've
taken over record city manager joey
mcdonald says music and movie sales have
increased substantially too
people are really getting back into
collecting vinyl records and that's
exciting to see and while there are
those customers who come in solely to
trade for profit
most come in for the love of the music
i'm not a trader i'm not a seller i'm
not any of it i'm
strictly a music lover i i think
there's a certain nostalgic element to
collecting i think people
associate a particular song with a
moment in their life for instance
and so i think that's part part of why
people collect
madison kimbrough 8 news now
i'm so bummed that i got rid of all my
big albums both
we're both regretting that oh my gosh
and i used to just love hearing the
needle that little scratch
you know when i first heard that i just
love that well that's a great point
that's how artists want you to hear
their music because it's not compressed
the music on our phone is compressed
it's digital
and that's that full sound even that's
how the artist wants you to hear it yeah
i'm sorry i'm sounding older now aren't
i
hey they're bringing back all those
records i love
i guess i do collect music i got a lot
of that you can always switch it's never
too late
our